i was keeping my my pregnancy pretty low
key
uh but uh unfortunately my mother has
instagram yeah moms and instagram go
together like oil and water
not a good mix and when emma roberts
stopped by jimmy kimmel live on monday
she opened up about how her mom kelly
cunningham
accidentally broke the news of her
pregnancy on the social media platform
mother's an instagram it's just it's a
bad combination
yeah and she uh she definitely she
spilled
spilled the beans the 29 year old mama
to be said she partially blames herself
for the mishap
because she recently replaced her mom's
flip phone with
an iphone it was the worst thing i ever
did it was that was a mistake
it started slow with like a google alert
on me
which she never had before so she's like
emma have you seen this photo
from 2010 i'm like yes i've seen that
photo and so i was getting flooded with
is this true and have you seen this and
that and i was like this was a bad idea
um
and then she got instagram yeah and it
got way worse
her mom got catfished by someone
claiming to be
jackson brown like the singer jackson
brown
and then of course her mom dropped the
baby bomb
it led to just interacting with my fans
and
you know just thanking them for all
their pregnancy
oh god it was a disaster um and i found
it all out on a plane so i couldn't get
to her
like i couldn't i couldn't call her or
or or
attack her emma's mom responded to
several fans who congratulated her on
becoming a grandma
after a tabloid reported that emma and
her boyfriend
garrett headland were expecting their
first child together
she was like thank you so much for the
well wishes we're so excited
i mean it was endless my friends were
sending me screen grabs
it was like unbelievable um and then
when i said to her i said mom you
revealed my pregnancy she goes emma
you announced it and i said no i didn't
that was a tabloid she's like
oh oh i didn't that wasn't clear
consider this your psa
silently delete instagram from your
mom's phone
and pray that she never figures out how
to retrieve it we kind of laughed
we kind of got in a fight i blocked her
at one point
it was my only weapon and she texted me
at 2 am queen did you block me question
mark
sad face and i was like yes i did block
you and then i unblocked her and it's
just it's been it's been an instagram
war with my mother that i never saw
coming
so all of that happened back in june and
in august
emma revealed they're expecting a baby
boy posting
these pics and writing quote me and my
two favorite guys
since then the american horror story
star has shared
several snaps of her growing baby bump
on instagram
and emma dished on the whole process of
picking out a baby name
i was convinced i was having a girl to a
point where i said to my boyfriend i was
like if it's a boy you can name it
meanwhile being like it's a girl so
who cares like now i'll get to name it
and then when we found out
he was like oh yeah so you said i get to
name him and i was like
i did say that didn't i that's so so
funny that i said that
but emma says her 36 year old leading
man eventually came up with the perfect
moniker
my boyfriend was was playing very hard
to get with me about the names i was
like we're having a baby you can tell me
like what you want to name
the baby and he was just very
tight-lipped and then he did finally
he came up with a winner that was really
good all of mine got vetoed for various
reasons
is it veto is the baby named vito
yeah the the baby